hallo leute bei mir ist es so wenn ich
aufgenommen habe und nachher die
aufnahme dann stoppe dann halte ich bin
dann mache ich mich in game mode und
macht fotos für die farm nails für die
einzelnen voll micro ich mir dann an und
gucke dann ja was kann ich denn hier ist
ein bild machen für diese folge
deswegen mache ich wieder am game mode
und ich habe keine lust mich dann wieder
im gaylord raus zu machen weil dann bin
ich oft irgendwo bobo dann gehe ich dann
immer wieder oben und noch ein foto von
monster falle dann mach ich halt das
ende für die aufnahme beziehungsweise
macht ein ende für da und dann bin ich
halt noch ein game dann bin ich halt
wieder aufnehmen will sich dann immer du
bist noch game 81 / game mode 0
und dann bin ich wieder aus dem thema
draußen dann kann nicht aufnehmen und
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass ihr wenig
wirklich so viel so erhöht so wenig
vertrauen zu mir habt und denkt dass
sich vorher zu orten fliege um dann zu
sehen dass da irgendwie bestimmte sachen
sind ich meine so nehm ich mir den
kompletten spaß an dem spiel und so hab
ich da eigentlich keine lust drauf wie
man das ist genauso als wenn man sich
dann in wie diamanten in dem let's play
titeln dann meint ja ich bin oft screen
rumgelaufen und hab dann gefunden also
das finde ich auch einfach total doof
wenn man sich so sachen bietet im let's
play
das haben wir bei sky blog glaube ich
ganz gut gepasst aber kann ihn nicht
getötet
aber das habe ich früher einmal gemacht
und mittlerweile es ist so wenn ich
titel finde ich hat das ding wie keinen
sinn an der adventure web zu machen
nur hier bei dieser adventure merk war
es so ich habe gesagt ich spiele die
nicht im hardcore-modus und ich will das
nicht beenden wenn ich sterbe deswegen
habe ich diese dinge in sveg enorm uhr
warum ist mein haus fällt ein
deswegen habe ich diese dinge einfach
weggenommen
diese challenge dass ich nicht sterben
soll weil ich keine lust drauf habe dass
ich wenn ich einmal sterbe alles vorbei
ist weil das war direkt in der ersten
folge so und dann wäre das 1 1 folgen
projekt geworden und darauf habt ihr
keinen bock drauf hab ich kein bock und
an dass alles gut
na ja gut ich weiß gar nicht wie viel
soll ich denn jetzt eigentlich noch
abfangen
reicht das nicht eigentlich schon für
die monster falle ich weiß nicht ich
komme gleich mal momente hat in facebook
angeschrieben muss mich beeilen nicht
während der aufnahme nicht während der
aufnahme auch köpfchen schnell auf dem
zweiten bildschirm das sollte euch jetzt
eigentlich bewusstsein moment im schnell
sodass blabla
also da bin ich hier es natürlich immer
ganz blöd ich hoffe ihr habt sich gehört
aber ich hab selbst aufblinken sehen und
das ist so in meinem augen winkel
entsteht also global tech i und message
tamblyn bling bling
na ja und ja ich habe meinen facebook
auf englisch ich höre die ganze nacht
nach oben ist zum er kann auch nur
überleben weil da glaube ich keine dinge
zu erkennen
sonne ich höre auch eine spinne ich
bestimmt da drin
anni war oben drauf ok ab geht's weiter
ich glaube das müssen wir schaffen oder
nee dat wird total eng mit den stein
das sehe ich jetzt schon aber es sieht
gut aus
ja man es passt okay die mutter fall ist
somit hiermit fertig das heißt wir haben
quasi hierzu die spawn flächen wo die
drauf spawnen werden dann darunter
geschäfte mal ganz kurz die dinge ins
auf normal damit ihr gleich eventuell
etwas bond dann mache ich das eben noch
zu so und dann haben wir fertig ich habe
fertig meister falle fertig auch da ist
auch was eine luft geflogen nicht habe
ich abgefangen stimmt monster falle auch
punkt vorgemacht finde mehr lava müssen
wir jetzt noch und einer kaktus farm
haben schon in kaktus haben wir auch
noch nicht
das heißt ich werde jetzt erstmal ein
wenig cobblestone fahren wir danach noch
ein paar ausrüstungen zu machen und dann
begeben wir uns mal auf die suche nach
weil es ein bisschen viel sticks danach
begeben wir uns auf die suche nach lava
und kakteen kakteen die nicht in die
finden acht wir müssen übrigens auch das
haben auch leute in die kommentare
geschrieben
danke dass ihr so aktiv in den
kommentaren seit dass ich da hinten
irgendwo da war eine eine mine
und da soll ich doch mal bitte hingehen
und das ist kein spoiler da wäre ich
sonst noch hin gegangen das habe ich
halt in der letzten aufnahme vergessen
deswegen wird alles ein bisschen doof
ich kann ich nach dem essen
zack zack zack zack
ich höre schon wieder irgendwelche
skelette und außerdem höre ich wieder
meine ganzen kühe immun ich glaube die
wollen einfach wieder ein bisschen power
zum vögeln bekommen will euer kind
mitmachen kann es nicht okay ein zweites
versteckt sich unter den beiden von der
mutter schön können wir die anderen
halten
so warte jetzt wollen wir noch ein
bisschen steine und ja ich weiß ist es
total uneffektiv mein ding ist hier aber
ich wollte einfach nur schnell ein coup
ist den red bull wird am 2 spitzhacken
jetzt damit zwei spielzeiten beschwert
somit eine schaufel zweite stoffe
überhaupt der spitzhacke schwert
schaffte schaufel bauen eigentlich noch
gar nichts mehr da reicht schon
ich glaubte transport gerade sogar
abwickeln einfach gleich ganz kurz nach
unten schauen spitzhacke spitzhacke
schaufel schaufel noch das mal ganz kurz
so schwertun 1,2 nach egal
passt schon bogen
die spitzhacke auch noch
essen bräuchten wir eventuell noch
details ich mach mir mal eben kurz ein
paar brote ja gut dann können wir jetzt
eigentlich schon auf die tür auf die tür
auf die tour gehen und uns eine mail
was willst du denn wir können einfach
wieder oben geht's aber richtig ab hallo
leute die sind ihr könnt alle daraus
scheiße ist total vergessen
wtf aber es geil ist die braut jetzt
alle noch einen schluss besser tot sind
und das ist eine ganz gute idee wäre ich
das so machen wir dann ganz viele feinde
ach du scheiße ist hab ich aber richtig
angst ist wieder alle gleiche luft
fliegen
ach du kacke
wtf geht das ab ich bin schon level 15
alter vater dass er schalke hatte
hecking zdf royal wtf ich will jetzt
noch nicht
ich gehe jetzt einfach mal runter und
lass das alles explodiert also eine
wundervolle haben wir aber das ist ja
geil
dadurch dass einfach vergessen abzubauen
dass er ganz lässig also sorry wenn ich
das ganze mache aber ich will jetzt mal
oder macht ihm einfach ganz kurz aus
damit ja ganz gut meine sachen
einsammeln kann aber das ist ja krank
guckt euch das mal an ich hätte ja nie
im leben gedacht dass das hier so abgeht
und guckt euch mal wie viele
schallplatten ich hab das ist ja heftig
krasse hat hätte ich nie im leben
gedacht dass das hier unten so abgeht
diese falle die hammer ist das denn
ich bin ganz voll begeistert ja gar
nicht was man das kurz zuvor ist das
geil kreis also da bin ich gerade echt
schon ein bisschen stolz auf mich dass
muss ich sagen muss ich mal so zu geben
jetzt ohne eigenen logo oder so wird hat
jetzt echt geil
obwohl sein einfach so übrigens alle
voll von bronk geklaut tut mir leid
freunde aber ich gucke grund nicht ich
weiß nicht wie seine falle aussieht und
das ist eine ganz simple monster falle
die jeder zweite let's play erbaut
also da tut mir echt leid wenn ich euch
enttäuschen muss das habe ich leider
nicht von ihm
so kann man hier ganz kurz weiter das
ist auf jeden fall wieder zu wenig
steine alter war das gras auf einmal
stehen also zehn millionen monster drin
naja
ich muss nicht die ganze touristen zu
mir leid das war richtig krass auf jeden
fall hat mich gefreut so jetzt die decke
fackeln habe ich die meisten wurde
weggesprengt
also ging es runter da oben ging es
runter wie krank war das denn bitte
das war schon in der hausnummer für sich
ich hab's auch total vergessen dass da
unten zu zu bauen
echt krass und vor allem wir haben ein
zwei drei vier fünf sechs schallplatten
sowie heftig ist das denn so können wir
jetzt eigentlich daraus panschen oder
also wir brauchen jetzt natürlich noch
ein bisschen fackeln um das hier
auszuleuchten
ich will wissen was ich las dass hier
erst mal so ich mache jetzt mal ganz
kurz wieder hier auf sie einfach mal
dann sollte eigentlich nicht allzu viel
kommen aber das ist schon krass vor
allem wie viele sachen von mir dabei
kaputt gegangen sind eigentlich voll
wenig für verhältnisse verhältnismäßig
wenig muss man dazu sagen
moment moment sodann eine schaufel die
axt war da krasse
hallo schaut mir und so habe ich mir das
vorgestellt
und da kommt die erfahrung und die items
ist eigentlich ganz egal
du packst es ein bisschen auch normal
stellen hier wieder das war schon krass
grad
das muss ich sagen da ging's richtig ab
du na ja gut wie viele fehler habe ich
zwölf ok cool
das war ganz interessant so viel muss
man sagen und das ist schon wieder nacht
das heißt wir können endlich wieder
pennen gehn und alter ich habe viele
level rotiert sich ausgepackt ich habe
übels viele level dabei verloren ich
hab' ich bin reingegangen hatte glaube
ich wird zehn crafter vom staat gerettet
chor crafter blue ab ich bin
reingegangen mit level 10 und bin
rausgegangen level ich hab mich selbst
abgeschossen bin rausgegangen mit level
15 watt irgendwie so und die belohnen
sind gewachsen
hier stellt gerade pumpkin fahren
brauchen wir auch noch war das dann
nicht in pumpkins dinges ich weiß es
galt gar nicht jedenfalls wir haben's
landsleute sind slams transport die
ganze sache einfach hier ein die ich
nicht brauche
26 knochen wird spricht er wohl für sich
und auch noch einer komm her schätzchen
das war knapp also die monster falle
funktioniert formidabel unterhalten
wieder ganz viel aktivität drin so
wartet ich schaue mal ganz kurz hier
eben noch mal kurz runter
auch die banken sich einfach nur aus
das skelett hatten bogen fallen lassen
läuft ja leute auf einmal spielt denn
die luft ich bin im moment wieder tot
das ist doch total kacke doch ich mach
das mal ganz kurzfristig muss ja auf
jeden fall noch irgendetwas vornehmen
aber die monster falle haben auf jeden
fall schon mal nein ich will dich titeln
für das arschloch weil es ist der ganze
sand ja auch unter gefallen die kag es
das denn man kann alles sortiert schade
egal jedenfalls sieht man dass die
monster falle schon mal ein klein wenig
funktioniert in einen gewissen abständen
soll wie sie jetzt natürlich noch ganz
kurzem ein inventar schwert war da zack
zack zack zack zack so total duda bau
und power 8 das liegt wieder antun wenn
die alte dieses komische - schaaf sah
hübsch das liegt wieder an themen die
items situation komischer backes oder so
so jedenfalls wollte ich nur noch mal
ganz kurz da hinten hinlaufen ich weiß
die folge geht und noch ein paar
sekunden
allerdings habe ich euch das versprochen
dass wir halt noch mal hin laufen
da ist ein williger nicht dass mein weg
punkte ja ich weiß mein wegpunkte ist
ein wenig komisch
so müsse jetzt ungefähr da langlauf mit
ihrem roten fleisches ganz gut so das
hab ich versprochen dass ich wenigstens
da noch im lauf das einzige was wirklich
noch brauchen seiner kaktus farm und
dass wir noch lava finden
ich weiß nicht ob wir nicht schon da war
gefunden haben haben wir noch nicht
gefunden
wir haben auch noch keine kakteen
vielleicht waren da hinten noch kakteen
ich weiß gar nicht oder ich habe
irgendwie verloren da hinter dem berg
ist das
und wir streifen durch die wüste die
savanne zieht weiter ich lauf hier
alleine durch die welt um alleine läuft
luke durch die fette groß wie viele
monster begegnen ihm
er sucht die oase doch die findet er
nicht denn der ist einfach nur ganz
schnell jetzt total behindert die war
jedoch ich tendiere zu total behindert
ohne schwan die war hier die war genau
hier hinter mich jetzt einfach zu blöd
wie hat kann nicht sagen wo ist die oase
hin bleibe ich einfach ein bisschen
falsch gelaufen
der luca der ist behindert denn der
findet sie einfach nicht die oase ist an
dem gleichen ort
er sucht sie auf seine wegen dort findet
sie nun endlich dann ist er da das sieht
es vorbei also hier war noch ganz viel
erde also er hat dort aber darunter ist
auf jeden fall nächstes heißt wir gucken
jetzt einfach mal ganz kurz in die mine
meint nämlich leute sollen die mine
gucken allerdings ist hier ja nix oder
also sieht nämlich so als wäre gar
nichts
jahre später ich glaube hier drin ist
nix und ich würde sagen dann machen
schon mal kurzen ende für die aufnahme
für heute und zwar sehen uns dann
einfach übermorgen im nächsten part
vielleicht schon im letzten ich glaube
es nicht aber es kann ja immer mal sein
dass das dann schon der letzte ist und
ich schaue hier schon den ganzen ob ihr
info kakteen sind aber jetzt nicht
einfach keine naja wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal tschüss wie mal wenn ihr
das wieder gut fand beteiligung hoch
andy schleck hat ein daumen runter
zschau